Speaker 1: Well, Omicron is everyone. Omicron
is everywhere rather, and we're going to talk
more about that a little bit later this
week. But we have another one of these
tragic stories in Michigan when the state issued
shutdowns for restaurants. There is a diner
that decided to stay open and the diner stayed
open because the diner's owner, John Paani,
decided to ignore the law. So the Quincy Diner
in Quincy, Michigan, stayed open, and John Paani,
the 62 year old owner, is now dead of COVID after
two months of fighting it. Now I have to tell you
this one is different from the typical
anti-vax nut believes COVID is fake and dies.
The guy was anti-vaccine, but this particular
story is extra tragic, and I'm not joking
here. This is not a joke. Back in December, when
Barney said I'm going to keep the restaurant open,
he said, My wife is fighting stage four
colon cancer. We depend on the restaurant
to help subsidize billing and all of that. My
employees need that. Of course, if I'd have stayed
closed much longer, I'd have lost the business.
So this is actually a story about many things,
and it's in great part a story about access to
health care. We say with universal health care,
there's no Breaking Bad, right? Walter White
doesn't need to start cooking meth to pay for
his treatment. If there is universal health care
and whenever I say that some of you will write to
me and you'll say, David, well, Walter White was
cooking meth to leave his family a nice nest egg.
Not just to pay for medical treatments. Fine.
But Walter White use the meth money to pay for
expensive treatments as well. And this guy, paani,
didn't just need to keep the restaurant open
to pay for his wife's cancer treatment.
He was also working full time at a casino.
Now it is also true that Paani was not vaccinated,
and that is 100 percent his choice. He told his
family he planned to get vaccinated after
he ended up in the hospital with COVID.
He never made it to that because he died, and now
there's a go fund me for his final expenses and
for his wife's continued cancer treatment, which
is still ongoing. She is. She is still with us.
So this is really a story about how much of a
mess this country is in. You've got a 62 year
old who's unvaccinated by choice. That's part of
the weaponized disinformation about the vaccines.
He catches COVID and it's really bad. That's one
story. We've heard that story a bunch of times,
and that's what happens to tons of people.
That's why you get vaccinated. There's no
doubt about that. But there's the other story,
which is he was working at his restaurant
and keeping it open and working at a casino to pay
for his wife's cancer treatment. And by the way,
if your wife has cancer, why on earth would
you not get a vaccine in order to protect her?
You care enough to keep the restaurant open in
defiance of the law to pay for her treatments,
but you won't even get vaccinated to protect her.
So there's a lot wrong with what this guy did, and
there's a lot wrong with this country. But this is
also a story about the broken health care system
as much as it is a story about anti-vaccine
ignorance as we have been talking about for a
while at this point in time. So another tragedy,
another ignorant guy who didn't get vaccinated,
but also a really depressing story about the state
of affairs with health care in the United States.